today was Hanson as a fellow at the
Hoover Institution and he joins us
tonight professor thanks very much for
coming on I keep noticing this
phenomenon where the farther behind
middle America rural America Falls the
longer you know the the death rate
continues to rise the life expectancy
continues to fall the more the people in
charge hate rural America they hate the
people who are suffering the most why is
that I don't know I'm speaking from
rural America and I can tell you that
it's phenomenal when you see there
concrete evidence in an empirical
fashion of when you have 3% annual GDP
growth or a record low peacetime
unemployment or 300,000 jobs created in
a year that's a moral act Tucker and the
Latino population I live in a community
that's 90 percent Latino is at record
lows and you can see it people were out
of heat they're working they have more
disposable income but rather than fixate
on that or even critique it we get back
to this not just that Trump is a Nazi
and by the way both of those clips the
speaker's had called Trump in his
supporters in the past nazi-like but
it's an attack on people and I thought
that was the whole purpose of the
politically correct movement you don't
stereotype an individual by demonizing
an entire group and then we we've got to
remember that this is not doing Tucker
all Wilson was doing was reach handling
I think his name was Caputo a political
reporter Uppal of months ago three or
four months ago went to a rally and say
that one person had more teeth and
everybody in the rally
you remember Peter struck saying that he
went into a southern Virginia Walmart
and heard he could smell the Trump
reporter and we have another FBI person
in that same text role that said Trump
supporters repeat POS pieces of blank
it's kind of the underbelly of the
deplorable Z redeemable and clingers at
Obama and Clint and Clinton used and
it's it's really ironic because they
have it
they're very elite themselves and they
think that by making fun of poor white
and they're mostly poor white
working-class people that earns them an
exemption from their own privilege as
being privileged
white people and then people like Hank
Johnson believe and remember he called
Israelis termites channeling of
Farrakhan they believe that they're
exempt because they're they have victim
status they can say whatever they want
but it's it's a sad commentary when the
entire political correct movement which
was designed to not use the offensive
speech the stereotype people turns out
to be nothing to do with principle but
power all along but have you ever seen
so you're a historian have you ever seen
a revolution aimed at the people below
aren't most revolutions from below
trying to seize power from the people in
charge this looks like the people in
charge trying to suppress the people who
don't have power yeah I think what we
have is we have a Versailles aristocracy
and they're very worried that people
outside the you know Versailles the
gates of Versailles are getting restless
and we see actually saw it in France and
I think they understand that whatever
they were doing and that was a devotion
to globalization optional optional wars
overseas stagnant economy this green
initiative and that was really hurting
people in the middle that a lot of
people were hurt by it and we had
created two Americas they're the winners
America on the winning coast and they
had to develop some type of exegesis to
explain why the people in the middle
were not doing well and rather than
saying their their jobs were outsourced
or we were offshoring or we were
neglecting our manufacturer they came up
with this self-fulfilling process
prophecy well they don't have teeth or
they stink or they didn't they're not
educated or they're worried about their
manhood and then that explains you know
a-to-z why they're not doing as well as
people in Malibu and the Upper West Side
and people are sick of it they're sick
of it because they're hypocrites Rick
Wilson went around in 2012 in a red
pickup I remember it in bragged he
carried a knife and he was going to
connect with the real people and help
MIT Romney get over his isolation on
Wall Street and so whatever that if it
paid better they'd do something else if
a Barack Obama wanted to build the wall
and he did at one time as did Hillary
Clinton then they would be saying the
wall is the greatest thing since sliced
bread it's political prostitution and
it's sad because we have a revolutionary
economic and foreign policy cycle going
on that's helping millions of people and
if they don't like it they should
criticize it on the principles bring
facts let's talk about the debt you know
what stop American citizens that we
think it's totally within bounds I it's
totally fine to attack politicians
including Trump by the way but when you
turn around and attack tens of millions
of your own countrymen something's
really wrong
I think bit shapes Hansen thank you very
much those too great to see you